in this lesson we're going to talk about
a reaction of aldehydes and ketones that
reaction involves addition to their
carbonyl group and we're going to look
at the addition of nucleophiles so
nucleophilic addition and just to
clarify these are the functional groups
that we're talking about today we have
our aldehyde with a hydrogen atom on one
side of the carbonyl and a hydrocarbon
group on the other side I'm just showing
a little stick here but this needs to be
carbon and we have our ketone with two
hydrocarbon groups one on either side of
the ketone it was important to make this
distinction because there are other
carbonyl containing functional groups in
organic chemistry some common ones are
acid chlorides esters and amides but
these different reactivity from the
aldehyde and ketone because they each
contain a potential leaving group so
they react by a different mechanism okay
first let's look at the properties of
the carbonyl group that'll teach us
something about its reactivity there is
an inductive effect in the carbonyl
group on the Pauling scale oxygen has an
electronegativity of 3.4 for well carbon
has an electronegativity of 2.5 5 so
we're seeing a difference of about 0.9
in relative electronegativity here with
oxygen being much more electronegative
than carbon so we can draw a dipole in
this molecule with a little arrow and
what this is helping us to show is that
the electrons are pulled more toward the
oxygen atom they spend more time
surrounding oxygen in the bonds that are
shared between carbon and oxygen because
of the double bond in this compound
there is also a resonance effect we can
draw an arrow that shows the double bond
breaking and an extra lone pair going to
oxygen I'm going to add on my lone pairs
so we can keep track of all the
electrons on oxygen and when we show
this electron flow we're moving
electrons away from car
and on to oxygen the resonance form
looks like this
so from this resonance form we can see
that carbon has all this positive
character we're going to be talking
about the interaction with nucleophiles
things with extra electrons things that
attack and so we're going to see
interaction at this carbon if you're
really new to this you might be like KP
how do I know to push my electrons up
onto oxygen well let me show you what
would happen if you push them the wrong
way we'll do this in red so we know that
it's bad okay so let's take the
electrons and push them on to carbon now
we're taking the electrons away from
oxygen putting them onto this carbon and
the resonance structure that we'll draw
now looks like this so we end up with a
positive charge on oxygen and a negative
charge on carbon if we look back at our
electronegativities oxygen is the more
electronegative atom so when drawing
resonance we want to put negative charge
on the more electronegative partner in
this double bond that's oxygen and we've
given it a positive charge carbon the
less electronegative element bares a
negative charge so this is incorrect and
I'm just gonna put a little X over it so
we can forget that that ever happened
okay
now that we know that the carbon of the
carbonyl has all this positive character
we can even say it's Delta positive and
to complete our dipole on this molecule
we can say the oxygen is Delta negative
now let's look at the mechanism of how
aldehydes and ketones will react with
nucleophiles here I've just shown a
generic nucleophile abbreviated nu it
has some extra electrons that it can
share in a bond that extra negative
charge is going to be attracted to the
electro positive carbon of the carbonyl
so we can draw an arrow for how the
nucleophile will attack like this now we
don't want to make five bonds to carbon
so we have to break a bond well that's
convenient oxygen is electronegative and
is pretty okay with holding a negative
charge so we're gonna push the double
bond up onto oxygen now let's draw the
structure we'll get one thing I want you
to notice is that
even though we're using this
abbreviation of a nucleophile that's
just very generic we're showing it with
a negative charge and we have a neutral
molecule reacting with a negative so
whatever we produce needs to be overall
negatively charged so we're good neutral
negative and we have a negative charge
on our oxygen in the product with a to
come together now in a second step we
can add in some acid which I'm just
going to abbreviate as H+ and we'll
produce an alcohol from this reaction
okay to learn organic chemistry we need
to learn our actual reactions so even
though we have a general sense that
nucleophiles can add we need to know
what the nucleophile is let's look at
some examples the first one we'll look
at is cyanide the nucleophile is CN
minus with a negative charge on carbon
sometimes we'll see this as a salt
sodium cyanide and the sodium we can
regard it as a spectator ion it's just
there to balance the negative charge
let's look at this reaction and see what
the cyanide anion actually looks like so
here we have a carbon triple bonded to a
nitrogen this will attack as in our
mechanism above and give us our
negatively charged intermediate we can
then add in a little bit of acid and get
the product of this reaction which is
called a cyanohydrin I'm going to add a
bond between my oxygen and hydrogen just
add the little line there so I can show
you something about this reaction this
reaction is reversible and if we treat
our cyanohydrin with a little bit of
base and warm it up we can deprotonate
the hydrogen atom take the electrons
from the o h bond and reform the
carbonyl and kick out cyanide this gives
us back our ketone and CN minus the
reason this reverse is so readily is
because cyanide is a good leaving group
another nucleophile that adds two
carbonyls is the acetylide anion this
nucleophile again has a negative charge
on carbon with a carbon-carbon triple
bond and an H on this end
the way that we can generate this is by
treating a settling with sodium metal
this gives us our anion and a sodium
plus that's hanging out this nucleophile
can add to our carbonyl the electrons
will bond here pushing up onto oxygen
from this we get our anion our alkoxide
that can be treated with a little bit of
acid to give our alcohol other common
nucleophiles that add to the carbonyl
group our organometallic reagents for
example we could add an alkyl lithium
here I'll show you lithium or an ethyl
grignard reagent here's ethyl magnesium
bromide now you might be wondering where
the heck is the negative charge
well these I'm drawing them like they
have a covalent bond here and they do
they have some covalent character in
this carbon metal bond however that bond
also contains significant ionic
character so we might think of our
grignard and our alkyl lithium as
looking more like this to see the
reaction so here we have the two carbons
of our ethyl group 1 2 with a negative
charge on it balanced by an Li plus and
for the grignard we can think about it
as looking like this the magnesium
carries a 2 plus charge and is balanced
by the carbon anion and the BR minus so
when you show attack using an alkyl
lithium or a grignard you can use either
form of these to really show the attack
if you're using this you'll show the
nucleophilic attack coming from the
carbon lithium bond and from the
grignard it'll come from the carbon
magnesium bond and just so I don't have
arrows going off into nowhere let's add
a little generic electrophile that it
can attack just a little e+ to represent
that so let's look at how this reacts
with our carbonyl compound now I'm going
to represent the organometallic reagent
with this form so 2 carbons are little
ethyl group with the negative on one end
and we're going to attack the electro
positive carbon
pushing the electrons up onto oxygen and
from this first step we get our alkoxide
with a new ethyl group on it coming from
the organometallic reagent and once that
reaction is completely done we can add
in a little bit of acid and get our
alcohol in this lesson we talked about
the inductive and resonance effects that
make aldehydes and ketones so special
and have this electro positive carbon
atom that can react with nucleophiles to
form alcohols we talked about three
examples of these nucleophiles cyanide
the acetylide anion and organometallic
reagents as ever thank you for watching
and I hope you learned something